fazeclan will be sold and the price
today is a cool $17 million for a
company whose public offering was pegged
to a $725 million value and who some
people valued as high as $1
billion it's a massive fall from grace
but can FaZe Clan bring back ogs like
temper Apex and Banks and actually save
this whole
thing
okay so let's start with the damage FaZe
Clan's public offering in July 2022 was
pegged to a
$725 million value when the deal was
announced on October 20th games Square
the purchaser of faas Clan announced
their intentions to merge the company
but keep it a wholly owned subsidiary
both boards for these companies have
already approved the deal which is set
to close in Q4 2023 shareholders have
yet yet to do so and games Square's post
merge valuation essentially gives us a
value of about $17 million for the phase
portion like most people who buy
companies they don't think it's worth
that amount they think it's worth a
whole lot more Justin Kenna games Square
CEO told digid Day quote the reality is
we're micro cap and we think we can get
a reating and this thing can move
quickly so by the time the deal closes
that could be materially different it's
all stock it's relative Okay so just
stick with me here for one second what
Kenna means to say is that he thinks the
market value of the Stock's current
Shares are currently undervalued and so
the actual value of the post merger
company is not guaranteed at this point
he's acknowledging that at least on
paper right now phas Clan is currently
smaller than a micro cap stock which
typically is used to refer to stocks
that have a value of 50 million to 300
million but he's arguing that this could
change pretty quick and becoming a micro
cap stock would mean that the combined
stock price of this new post merger
company would Crest 50 million but why
would we expect that to change exactly
well let's take a little look at game
square games Square owns complexity so
in a way this whole phase thing kind of
makes a lot of sense complexity has been
around even longer than phze clan in
Esports now it's Lord and Steward is
Jerry Jones owner of the Dallas Cowboys
Jones was already involved in complexity
but games Square acquired complex
completely in 2021 paying $27 million it
also boasts Kenna as CEO as I mentioned
and ninja yeah that ninja as their Chief
Innovation officer according to their
website they also own code red Esports
an agency for players and talent in the
industry and beyond that a bunch of
media companies in the space games
square has also been active in snapping
up other companies they merged with
engine gaming and media nearly a year
ago but in that case seem to have merged
everything into gamees square but I
think it's also fair to say that phase
is a different beast from complexity
both in origin but also probably in
demographic but what is it that makes
phase phase well if you want to get that
old school phase feel maybe you bring
back the ogs and that's exactly what's
happening here once the deal is complete
banks will return as CEO temper will be
president and Apex will be coo the
release goes on to say that quote
Founders are focused on refreshing the
phas clan brand re-engaging with its fan
base and empowering individual Phase
Clan creators and their communities end
quote but here's the thing while the
founders may have some control over what
happens it's not like they wholly own
the company something that another phase
OG rain has been quick to point out in
an Instagram story he noted that the
phase OG still wouldn't have control of
the company they'll be merging into
banks for his part said that people
needed to be patient for change since
the deal would still take a while to
close n shot seemed excited about
Banks's return to the boardroom too I
also think it's fair to talk about the
elephant in the room here which is what
exactly does re-engaging with the fan
base mean for these three guys part of
the core of what the OG phase was all
about was cross promotion if you were an
upand cominging Creator there was this
huge audience that wanted to watch your
stuff maybe they already kind of were
but once you joined FaZe Clan it was a
whole different level over time the phas
cast of face has changed but content has
changed a lot since the beginning of
phase 2 full respect to these guys but
it's not like Banks and Apex are making
tons of videos on YouTube nowadays but
you know Banks he was pretty confident
saying he'd get phased back past its
alltime high and honestly I'm excited to
see what they try to do and yeah we're
getting Modern Warfare 3 the 2 this year
so sniping montages May in fact be in
the zeist but still it's hard to imagine
FaZe making a full comeback like this
it's hard to know how any of this will
go but let me put it to you another way
if FaZe is going to make a comeback they
have to start somewhere for FaZe fans
this is hopefully the bottom something
clearly had to change at phze it now has
and so for the first time there's a
direction for FaZe to like change course
to write a new history I guess in that
sense it's a good thing if you're a fan
at least now there's a path forward does
this merger solve everything
automatically for faas well clearly not
and there's a lot of hard work ahead I'm
sure some of which has already been
started by Banks and the others it's a
shot at least and if there's early heat
around this new Phase Clan Direction
maybe we even could see the stock get
rated like McKenna suggested one last
thing that we need to talk about here
though and that's that under the gamees
square umbrella we now have both
complexity and phase two separate
Esports organizations and in some
Esports both those organizations have
teams right now that includes Apex
Legends rocket League Halo FIFA and
fortnite but the conflicts also include
Counter-Strike as I'm sure you've
noticed from that list and at the recent
IM Sydney tournament Bas Clan won the
whole thing complexity were the runners
up it seems like a clear problem for
competitive integrity and let's not
forget valve has already worn teams
ahead of Counter-Strike 2
that the scene needs to be more open and
more transparent there have already been
reports about the future of some of ph's
roster though so maybe a future
consolidation is already in the works
who knows now listen if the phze brand
were hypothetically retired in csgo to
make way for complexity there I'd be
incredibly sad sure the default FC in
red is maybe not the craziest logo on
the planet with the red blue yellow
check it out that thing slapped for now
we have to wait to see how the merger
shakes out but also how fazeclan which
will then be a wholly owned subsidiary
will start to rebuild its
Empire